elles sont vertes parfois brunes
possèdent des tâches marrons des tampons
en forme de cercle peuvent peser jusqu'à
1 kg et sont connus sous le nom de
grenouille taureau
avec son cri qui peut se faire entendre
dans un rayon de 500 mètres cette espèce
exotique XXL originaire du continent
américain qui prolifèrent à vitesse
grand V dans nos lacs et nos étangs et
qualifiés d'envahissante et préoccupe de
nombreux pays
de vérifier si cet étang possède des
têtards de grenouille taureau les
grenouille taureaux qui mangent souris
serpents et autres poissons perturbent
les écosystèmes et menacent les autres
espèces à tel point que les États-Unis
ont même demandé à leurs habitants de
les attraper pour les manger alors les
gros nuls taureaux vont elles nous
envahir
elles arrivent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand une femelle pond 10000 à chaque
fois chaque pompe donc c'est énorme et
on ne sait pas pourquoi quelqu'un les a
importés en France en 1968 depuis les
États-Unis c'est une erreur fondamentale
parce qu'elles vont détruire
l'écosystème il faut s'en méfier
vraiment elle mange les autres
grenouilles elles mangent les poissons
les voir écrasées ça me font le
coeurs
c'est un beau message ok bravo à toi non
mais c'est vrai bravo à toi Kelly
mais je m'en fous
je suis grenouille
c'est vachement ils ont des cuisses
énormes ça doit être génial bouffer non
si c'est comestible
de poulet non non
aucune cuisse aucune cuisse
et des Hulk pardon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est contaminée